qui est le corbeau c'est la question clé
du procès villemin 1 dijon en effet de
l'identité du délateur dépendra en effet
la vérité sur le meurtre du petit
grégory
on attendait beaucoup de l'audition cet
après midi de l'un des frères de jean
marie villemin
michel contrevenu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan bruno girodon entre michel du
villemin et son ex femme ginette silence
et chuchotements jean-marie le frère est
persuadé que plusieurs membres de sa
famille savent la vérité
tous pourtant depuis hier défilent à la
barre depuis novembre cherchent on ne
comprend pas résultat on soupçonne tout
le monde pour la défense michel ongles
de grégory et copain de bernard laroche
apparaît comme l'informateur possible du
corbeau en z je vois qu'à des scouts
journée j'ai rien à dire
claerbout recoucher on disait les
joueurs étaient très résistants ceux ci
ont dû s'occuper mais bon je vais relire
larouche ne s'est pas ouvert leur lot de
combos et c'est pas beau cambo les bains
en prime est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à dire
java régis pas le parler oui oui parler
alors oui pourquoi je vais trop loin de
la famille
pourtant il perdu son fils sa vérité
comme nous rachète en quoi il a fait du
malade
rapidement pourtant ce soir michel
s'adresse à son frère crois-moi
jean-marie je ne mens pas moi aussi je
veux savoir la vérité monsieur le
président seulement aujourd'hui il y à
jean marie qui m'accuse je regrette
michel mais je n'accuse pas à quelques
mètres de là dans une autre salle que
celle où se tient le reste de la famille
villemin se trouve christine ainsi elle
n'a pu entendre ses beaux frères et
belles soeurs dire qu'aujourd'hui il la
croit innocent un peu comme si on
voulait donner aussi enfin l'image d'une
famille